fresh and fit decides to hit us with
dozens of copyright claims we saw this
was probably going to end up coming and
uh honestly not upset about it at all
they apologized to us for some of the
comments that they made in regards to
preach significant other and then
afterwards today recently they decided
to copyright claim the video that we
didn't respond to their apology
so so imagine being like yeah you know
we [ __ ] up we take accountability we're
sorry okay you know we're like oh this
is how we feel about your apology
copyright clip
so we received all the claims as you
guys can go look through our YouTube
videos the videos are still there and
we'll get to why that is later they feel
like they're in the right in doing so so
I'm going to play a clip from their
Channel which again they might copyright
click but I'm still going to play so you
guys can get the full context because I
could explain it myself but
I don't want to yeah bro you know what
I'm saying like we're back you know what
I'm saying the haters tried to kill us
over 30 plus YouTube channels made
videos like slander our name whatever it
is now they're mad that they're get
there's consequences actions bruh y'all
are not gonna be able to run around and
drag our name in the mud with you know
falsely without some kind of recourse
bro like that's just not the way the
world works and it's because your your
reality is ours doesn't mean that we're
wrong like we live this lifestyle this
is who we are yeah bro so hey man you
know this bro someone in mind that they
can't do what we do that's what it
really is man yeah facts you know what
I'm saying and I don't want it to our
own horn but think about it bro Monday
we talk to you guys about making money
right we brought Grant card on Robert
Kiyosaki you know what I'm saying
critically acclaimed authors guys that
are multi-millionaires billionaires on
the show teach you how to make money
Wednesdays we talk about dating right
you know what kills me about these guys
they always talk about yeah we're making
men's lives so much better our channel
is about doing all this stuff if you go
look at the videos on their videos none
of them are on the videos where they're
supposedly helping men none of the men
are tuning in for financial advice the
men are not doing in for Fitness advice
they're not too even know that you know
what they tune in for women getting
dunked on Bimbo's getting kicked out so
I think this whole like disingenuous
thing where you're like we're helping me
to get better I mean I'm sure there's a
small section of men who are
appreciative your brain is built on
dunking on women with these supposed
facts that you have and it's okay it's
okay but it's a bit of a lie that's like
saying McDonald's is known for their
salads it's like rough yes we know you
offer it but [ __ ] give me a
double cheeseburger and get on it pronto
and you know what kills me about these
guys is that they're gonna sit there and
talk about like don't you can't react to
our stuff it's ours go on their Channel
and they react to other people's content
all the time without asking them for
permission before
here we are to kick off the hood
Olympics 2021 so uh let's continue on
hang up easily from that finally found
it I was with fresh talking about some
other stuff and this talks about public
transportation oh this scene right here
comes from the first game that they play
which is red light green like we all
know this game we're gonna play uh some
uh Clips I guess you're from Instagram
Clips this guy we're gonna play stop
clips and get a reaction so ladies we
want your honest reaction to these
videos and don't hold back okay we're
gonna react like a second clip here guys
we're gonna play the video uh from
Worldstar and this video went viral on
Tick Tock just to give you guys a little
bit of a background
um this guy came on and talked about how
he got divorce great uh we're gonna play
the entire video and react to it so this
idea that you guys think you can react
to other people's content without
permission and that that's perfectly
safe but that others doing that to you
is somehow completely different blows my
mind but again I'm not mad at you guys
doing it because guess what that's fair
use in the same token what we do is fair
use now you may disagree get your
lawyers involved we'll see what happens
to the YouTube appeals process but it's
clear to me
these guys are butt hurt that they're
tired of getting exposed even though
they're really the ones exposing
themselves your boy academics put you on
blast
and because they're so butt hurt right
and they're getting tired of being
called out this is the approach they're
taken but the reason why they're mad is
that we're not going to give you guys
the oxygen and talk [ __ ] about you and
give your give say your name what we're
going to do is we're going to go behind
the scenes get the legal people to do it
for us and then they're going to hit you
guys where it really hurts your pockets
okay you make a hit piece on us we're
going to hit you back but legally we're
not going to give you guys oxygen talk
about you and say your name and give you
the cloud that you want we're going to
hit you where it hurts all right make
videos on us there's consequences to it
you know what I'm saying any many big
YouTube channels do this if you use
their stuff and copyright they're gonna
hit you with a strike okay so that's a
that's a big lie that he tells many
YouTube channels listen we cover Jubilee
off time they're far larger than you
guys far larger than us we cover a bunch
of large YouTubers and they do not do
what you are describing people keep
bringing up Kevin Samuels Kevin Samuel
strikes down people who use his entire
stream fair use I think is very
confusing to people because they don't
really understand it in the commentary
Community for example it is considered
fair use to use other people's work
provided that you meet a certain set of
criteria so it's not always black and
white but let me explain if if you grab
a clip and then add commentary
surrounding it the work becomes
transformative it is not a substitute
for said product because of the fact
that you are creating something unique
through your commentary and through your
own individual brand that is what fair
use is it's kind of like when we are yet
Al Yankovic was covering a bunch of
Michael Jackson songs taking the exact
same beat but using his own lyrics as a
parody parody is considered fair use
it's transformative therefore it's fine
this has been
um handled in court already by h3h3 in
the previous case which you guys can go
check out in the description below but
yes you guys can use other people's
content provided you transform it by
using your own commentary your own edit
links editing skills to make it a very
different thing all right now of course
there's going to be some caveats it
depends on how much of the work that you
use how much of their work is your work
meeting if you just clip somebody and
use 100 of their video and that's your
entire video that's not considered fair
use because you haven't transformed the
work and that is what oftentimes
YouTubers will take down but if
someone's doing commentary reaction
people don't really touch that generally
speaking okay so I just wanted to clear
that up for the viewer who doesn't
really understand how it works Kevin
Samuels does it I don't see none of
y'all saying nothing about Kevin Samuels
oh okay
so yeah
anyone that has a branch of protect is
going to do everything they can to get
rid of people that make false
allegations and slander if y'all they're
talking the truth fine whatever but the
other [ __ ] nah man if you want to put up
someone for defamation do that
file a lawsuit and say defamation go try
it good luck in court
go do it
but I'm using the copyright system
because you don't want to go through the
litigation process of actually taking
someone to court for defamation that's
going to fall back on you I want to let
you guys know as the viewers that it's
not an issue for us
um if it needs to go to court we can
take it to court y'all know me I'm Dusty
they call me Dusty they say yo this man
never had a haircut and everybody's new
clothes you're right okay I bought one
sweater in the last two three years I'm
good you know what that means I save my
money so if you want to take it there we
can it's not an issue for me whatsoever
I'm not a big spender all right you guys
are living that Miami lifestyle spending
your money left right and Center go
ahead
today I got time because when it comes
to this situation I think this is their
attempt at getting back at the folks
that they feel have aggrieved them all
right and if you want to go through that
route
do you but I will say this it's in the
terms of service it's in the policy if
you abuse a copyright system for reasons
like this your channel can be terminated
at the end of the day guys I don't want
your channel to be gone why because you
know you guys say a lot of dumb stuff
and I make money off of the dumb stuff
that you say if you guys want to know
how this whole thing is going down
between fresh YouTube and all this other
stuff I'll be posting another video
later on tonight so go check that out
hopefully preach will be around for that
one